so Donald Trump has signaled that he
might be abandoning the anti-vaccine
movement that he sort of placated since
the Republican primary debates of 2015
and 2016 you might recall that Donald
Trump has parroted so-called vaccine
skeptical claims dating all the way back
to the Republican debates and first I
want to tell you what's new about this
and then we'll go back the measles
outbreaks are continuing to happen and
the anti-vaccine movement in certain
enclaves in certain parts of the United
States keeps growing and we were having
measles outbreaks and Donald Trump was
recently asked about it of course as his
helicopter was making all sorts of noise
in the background and Trump is now
saying people simply have to get their
shots because this is becoming a problem
take a look at what he said
[Music]
this is a big change for Trump because
during the 2016 campaign Trump parroted
the idea that vaccines cause autism
which is a totally debunked claim by a
doctor who lost his medical license
after putting out a so-called study
which has since been retracted but think
back to Donald Trump in 2012 for example
where he tweeted massive combined
inoculations to small children is the
cause for big increase in autism in 2014
Trump was tweeting the same stuff quote
healthy young child goes to doctor gets
pumped with massive shot of many
vaccines doesn't feel good and changes
autism many such cases
here's Trump during the 2016 debate
talking about this autism has become an
epidemic
25 years ago 35 years ago you look at
the statistics not even close I am
totally in favor of vaccines but I want
smaller doses over a longer period of
time and you pump I mean it looks just
like it's meant for a horse not for a
child two years old two and a half years
old the child a beautiful child went to
have the vaccine and came back and a
week later got a tremendous fever got
very very sick now is autistic this is
the President of the United States now
okay that this is really really
dangerous stuff and then during his
transition period between November and
January xan dog Eurasian Trump invited
vaccine skeptics to Trump Tower to talk
to him about being on vaccine
Commission's or something but then now
let's look at it one more time again
Trump says it's getting bad and people
just need to get their shots
[Music]
so the anti-vaccine movement is not
happy with Donald Trump about this but I
have to tell you Trump's doing the right
thing here okay it's disgusting that we
have a president who ever touted
debunked autism vaccine stuff okay I
mean it's embarrassing internationally
it's embarrassing domestically it's one
of the thousand things that are idiotic
that Donald Trump has said he's done
tons of damage on countless fronts by
repeating this stuff previously it's a
small thing but it's something that he
is now saying this which it will
hopefully prevent some people from
skipping their kids vaccinations and
we'll get some additional kids the MMR
vaccine or whatever vaccines they are
that their doctors are recommending and
while we're on the topic of this
BuzzFeed news tried to do something that
I think is valuable which is they went
to all the twenty20 Democratic
candidates and ask them about their
views on vaccines and basically everyone
is for vaccines on the Democratic side
that everybody who commented and
otherwise they had to look at sort of
what's on the record for people who
didn't directly respond to BuzzFeed news
the only notable thing was that Pete
Buddha jej says that he's okay with
religious exemptions to vaccinations if
a state doesn't have a problem of low
vaccination rates which to me is a very
dumb position because allowing the
religious exemptions can cause a problem
with vaccination rates and it's a really
weird sort of circular thing you're okay
with religious exemptions if the state
has a high vaccine rate but by allowing
them it lowers the vaccine rate which
might cause a problem which would then
get him to say well I'm actually no
longer for religious exemptions and the
position was so stupid that he sort of
took it back and now says that medical
exemptions are the only ones that should
be allowed so a very very quick
turnaround and otherwise I think I've at
least not seen I don't know what like
marianne williamson 'he's position is on
vaccination but
she's polling like less than zero if
that's even possible so I'm not I I
didn't research her position but none of
the even remotely serious presidential
candidates on the left on the Democratic
side have said concerning things about
vaccines that I've been able to find let
me know what you think about this
reversal from Trump does he even
recognize it as a reversal or is it
again one of these things of he just
says whatever comes to mind even if it
directly contradicts himself from a year
ago or two years ago I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show I want to hear from you
respectfully with peace and love but I
do want to hear from you today's sponsor
is Skillshare and I'm excited to tell
you that everybody in our audience is
getting two entire months of free access
to Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video skill shares the
site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]